obviously we just went through a massive
recession what industries do you think
are just recession proof you talk about
laundry mats and car washes all the time
what what industries do you look at to
kind of be recession-proof to hedge
yourself against that well more than
ever and you guys get this i think it's
not just industry it's geography i
used to think that geography meant uh
international like do i want to invest
in the us do i want to invest in china
do i want to invest in emerging markets
now i'm like do i want to have zero
exposure in california the answer is yes
and do i want to have more exposure to
what i call freedom markets so like
oklahoma texas um you know alabama
florida and so before even sector
specific if you're thinking about
actually buying starting a business and
running one you need to do it in markets
that allow for good regulatory
environments which basically mean like
protect us keep us safe but then kind of
get out of the way so that would be the
first thing then the second thing that i
focus on are anywhere during the
recession that the businesses were
allowed to stay open it's a really weird
paradigm shift that we now have to
consider that the government at any
point in time could shut down your
business and mandate that you lose any
income source and so i like to look at
what were those industries that kept
going which is why i invested cannabis
it's why i invest in things like
laundromats because they're deemed an
essential service so there's a list of i
don't know 35 40 different types of
businesses that are allowed to stay open
um and i would do that and heck another
friend and
maybe i have some interesting friends
but i think as it turns out just people
are more interesting than you give them
credit for um
and uh you know i have a couple friends
that made a ton of money on um oh my
gosh places to go get
shots obviously during the pandemic and
swabs like those little tents you know
you see those popped up everywhere you
can go get a wrap and test they're
making
millions of dollars a year and they cost
basically nothing to set up and you set
them up on the back of a doctor's
insurance so you don't even have to be a
medical professional it's it's wild yeah
i've seen some of the ones at uh
sporting events or concerts and stuff
like that and the lines out the door i
know some of these uh sporting events it
was literally like hey if you do this
you get a discount inside or something
like that and it makes you think right
like that's a weird incentive they're
obviously doing something to incentivize
themselves to do that right so uh that's
fascinating to hear the amount of money
that's being made one more thing cody
i'm glad you brought up laundromat so
one thing that i've i've seen a lot with
people who are selling their laundry mat
right um they want to basically get away
from the laundromat business how do you
think about when you're going to acquire
or just even look at buying a laundry
mat um the managers and all that because
most of them are family-run businesses
and they want to stop doing it which is
why they're selling their entire
business yeah such a good question um i
mean people sell businesses for a myriad
of reasons but usually they're like sick
older
bored need to move right those are some
of the most common and so you know how i
like to think about buying a business is
it's just a trade just because you buy a
business now doesn't mean that you need
to keep it forever which is how i would
have thought about buying a business
even 10 years ago i would think like now
i am a laundry matter and all i do is i
think about laundromats and in reality
that's not the case um instead you could
have a business for a period of time
until you grow to the next one so for
somebody that was first time buying out
and starting with laundromat by the way
i'm not like obsessed with laundromats i
just use it as an example because it's
super easy to understand instead of me
explaining like oh i do a roll up and i
add another company and then we do a
reverse merger that's like kind of a lot
so we talk about laundromats but it
could be just about anything
but i think you should think about it as
this is your first little foray and so
do you want to be tied to this business
for like a year sort of figure out the
business and then get somebody in to
operate it for you so you can keep
a little bit involved maybe not that
involved or do you want to scale it and
have four or five or six or seven or 20
laundromats and then you build a
business on top of it and then you can
create get creative like we invested in
one here in austin called the fold
and most laundromats are used at about
30 utilization so lots of empty uh
laundry machines they took it up to 70
because they add wash and fold services
to delivery to apartments and so um you
know you can add lots of different types
of businesses but i would just ask
yourself do i want to do this for what
period of time if not long can i get an
operator in place or can i sell the
business